hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
bio safety enclosures and the automated
lab steps for success
i am jennifer woods of lab roots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labruz and brought to you
by labconco
to learn more visit labconco.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please follow the process to obtain your
credits by clicking on the continuing
education credits window
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
david wafesha
director of biosafety products at
labconco corporation
and simon fogerty director of
application sciences at tcan
david and simon you may now begin your
presentations
thank you jennifer good morning good
afternoon everybody
what i'd like to do is do a short
presentation first
before david takes the floor um
and talk about some of the sort of main
considerations for
containment of automated liquid handlers
so firstly when you look looking at
containment
you as a as an instrument owner you've
got
two real options firstly you can have a
simple
hood that sits on top of the instrument
um
these can be connected directly to uh
in-house exhaust or come incorporated
with
a simple hepa or charcoal filters
depending on whether you're dealing with
biologics
or chemicals and can provide
filtration of the air after after it's
been sort of handled in the instrument
either
blowing air down onto the work surface
for a clean air
or an extraction based system
the second option you have is a fully
enclosed system
these offer a lot more flexibility in
terms of having a bigger
area that you can put plates and tubes
etc down
in front of as you're loading the
instrument
can house additional components such as
plate carousels which you can see there
on the right hand side of the photo on
the right
the instrument on the right you can also
incorporate
other integrated devices behind or
or below the liquid handler and build a
much larger system
these are obviously though sort of more
custom designed
but they are they are an option for you
obviously also the other consideration
to have
uh when choosing these is what space is
available in the lab
the other major consideration and david
will david will talk a lot more about
this
in his presentation is is to think about
it in airflow you can't just
put a liquid handling type instrument
into a standard hood
and hope that it'll work well
regular laminar flow hoods are designed
for a small number of obstacles in there
such as media bottles and flasks
when you put in a large instrument you
have to consider the instrument itself
and how the airflow will work
[Music]
and that's very much part of the design
of the the types of huds that we offer
and put together
you've also got to consider the the
accessibility
there's uh two types of accessibility
are needed the
daily operator access where you're going
to be loading in plates
tips reagents etc and then physically
taking out those
out at the end of a run you've got to
make sure that the operators can
reasonably access all parts of the
instrument in the work deck
often times we'll have and you can see
it in the photo here
at the bottom at the back um plate
hotels
uh hotels for tips etc there's got it
those have got to be sort of
realistically accessible by the lab
staff
you also need to have uh less routinely
needed but still
important that access for engineers
for to provide routine maintenance and
repair as well
so you see in this system there's a a
lower door for
daily access and routine use of the
instrument
and larger doors at the top and at the
side as well
for actual service and maintenance of
the instrument
so again this has to be sort of thought
out in your design
for many of the instruments we'll
actually take off
our safety doors when we install these
uh into a into a hood the reason for
that
is to uh allow good airflow within the
instrument
and often end up replacing the safety
interlocks on our instrument
with safety interlocks on the actual
hood and enclosure itself
and wire those into the into the
operating system of the instrument
so you maintain that safety lock system
but it's actually changed from being
directly on the instrument
to being part of the actual enclosure
itself
and again you know this this is this is
an important aspect of the
design of the other hood systems that
you'll
you'll need to purchase
cleaning is another key consideration
um with a large expensive liquid
handling instrument inside a hood you
can't just bomb it with formaldehyde
like you would do
for a regular laminar flow hood with
nothing in it
um you can wipe down the instruments
with something like 70
alcohol and for our liquid handlers
we recommend hydrogen peroxide vapor we
do need to be careful about what you
select you do need to have that
in as a consideration in your design
of the systems you're going for the work
you're going to be doing
and the cleanup protocols that you need
to put in place
to ensure that not only you're able to
sort of keep the
hood and the instrument clean and
decontaminated
but also that you don't do any component
damage
to the instruments
and finally there are two answers that
you should have at your fingertips
when you first start looking at
enclosures and the types of hoods you
need
know your biosafety level that you need
to achieve
both us and labconco can work with you
and define a system that will meet those
needs but we'll take our guidance from
you
uh you should as a user know you know
what cells you're handling with
what chemicals what requirements you
need
second question and it's it's a trivial
one but it
catches people off guard
and there's nothing worse than
forgetting to address this
uh and discovering on delivery day that
the ceiling is too low but
make sure you know how tall your ceiling
is more importantly also make sure you
know
if there are any restrictions in place
height wise related to how close
enclosures can be to the top of the
ceiling and also
any restrictions with regard to how
close enclosures can be to venting
and any other services within the
ceiling
we have a number of design options that
can address different ceiling heights
um but this you know how tall is your
ceiling and what are the restrictions on
things like venting will be uh
will be the second question we ask
and with that i'd like to say thank you
and hand you over to david who will
go into some of these aspects in in much
greater detail
thanks so much simon and thanks everyone
for joining this morning
or afternoon depending on where you are
um i'll click through one last slide uh
thanks thanks again to t can for uh
joining this presentation
um at this point i want to talk a little
bit about uh
some of the opportunities uh for
integration of automated instruments
into
larger enclosures from labconco and i'll
cover a lot of the considerations that
you need to
take into account just like simon
covered as well
and and we'll also look at some options
for containment of different platforms
uh so the first thing just to touch base
on what
simon was discussing is uh really
understanding the
adherence and the guidelines that you
need to comply with to
ensure that your laboratory is carrying
out all of its operations safely
and so for many of you these are answers
that that come to you
in the form of skilled recommendations
from your biosafety officer or
representative
in environmental health and safety a lot
of the guidances typically come from
well-known organizations like the cdc
and it's bmbl which just received
an update to the 6th version and also
the other
organizational guideline guidances like
cdc guidelines um
uh so just jumping ahead now um
uh so just some of the the
the uh organizations are out there again
uh cdc
world of health um uh
all great uh sources of information
you'll also find
uh the isac guidelines for flow
cytometry
or uh are another great spot to look if
you're looking for
for help with salesforce information
and and then certainly institutional
guidances as well so if your
you know organization has additional
requirements that go beyond these
documents it's important to look at
those
and and check with your and consult with
your bio safety officer on site
as simon was saying there are a handful
of
different opportunities for containment
out there
in the form of live congo uh products
those
are the next three that'll be displayed
on this
slide it involves most simply as a clean
bench or a laminar
air flow hood this is a downflow
sometimes they exist
in horizontal flow designs and
many liquid handler instruments out
there have options for these to be
purchased
fully integrated it's worth mentioning
however though
that the the only protection that
is provided by this type of enclosure is
product
protection or sample protection so while
you can achieve
the elimination of cross contamination
and room contamination of your samples
there's no protection for users
on the other hand there are negative
pressure containment options out there
for biological hazards
these are typically referred to as class
1 bscs as defined by the cdc's bmbl
and at the same time also a more
simplistic enclosure
providing just personnel protection for
a user so they're able to contain
biohazards and other materials of
particulates
with particulates but they offer no
protection from
outside contamination or
cross-contamination within the enclosure
so for sensitive assays that require
aseptic conditions these could be
problematic
so the last and perhaps most prevalent
biosafety enclosure out there is what's
known as a class 2 bio safety cabinet or
class 2 enclosure
and these marry the principles of clean
benches and class 1 bscs to produce both
personnel and product protection
and that creates a safe environment that
remains aseptic
also worth noting class one and class
two bscs are all
suitable for bsl to work and above uh
with with uh consultation from your
responsible safety officer but uh
wanna just uh note that it's really
important to look at that component just
as simon had mentioned earlier that
that is a piece that you need to
understand and and live conco and others
cannot provide guidance on
which is the right level of safety for
your organisms
now looking at standard class 2
biosafety cabinets
these have been around for 50 some odd
years
we know they provide personal and
product protection and then of course
environmental protection by not letting
any biohazardous materials back into the
laboratory
and really class 2 bscs are designed for
manual work
so they're designed to be regularly
used by a human inside the hood and to
handle
things like cell culture flasks reagent
bottles
and other things that are smaller in
size
if we visualize airflow within the
enclosure
you can see on this slide you may have
to click play if it's not already
playing
but you can see the downflow smoke uh
within the cabinet
this is representative of unidirectional
air or sometimes
laminar air and it represents a
clean straightforward path of airflow
downward in the cabinet
this is the principle that helps keep
things clean as it comes out of the hepa
filter
also helps to ensure that there's a
limited cross contamination or no cross
contamination as the airflow
sweeps contaminants and pulls them into
the air vents at the front and back of
the hood
um so as you can see with a user's hands
in there the laminar flow is not
heavily disrupted but if you take up
that space
with a large instrument or large
materials it can readily disrupt that
airflow
and restrict its pathway to the vents
which means that it can cause turbulence
and that may impact the samples or worse
potentially impact the safety of the
user
so if we look at on the screen is a is
the tcan evo platform
and roughly uh these units
are about 30 inches in depth and if you
look at the inside of a typical
biosafety cabinet
across all different types of models out
there you'll see a number of dimensions
listed
but the working depth is is typically
representative of the work tray or the
actual space available in the enclosure
and even though some instruments may fit
into a biosafety cabinet
knowing the compatibility and the
dimensional fitment of that unit
inside the hood does not necessarily
ensure that airflow will remain
safe certainly if you're a safety
officer on this presentation you've seen
an overloaded fume hood or a biosafety
cabinet and that is
one of the most disruptive practices to
the airflow that
ensures the product will function
correctly so
as you compare the sizes it's really
important not just to look at
the available uh dimensions inside the
hood but the available
dimensions plus a perform you know an
envelope around the instrument
to ensure good containment
to look at this a little bit more
closely here's a couple of examples with
some instruments
on the left there's a liquid handler on
the right it's an automated bioreactor
and many times
the dimensions of the product will fit
within the enclosure
but may block really important parts of
of
biosafety cabinets in particular on the
left you can see this is the smallest
configuration
that this instrument allowed and is
while it does sit inside the enclosure
and can operate functionally without any
disruption from the sash it covers the
front airfoil which means that
the biosafety cabinet itself does not
have the ability to
properly function and contain while
keeping samples within the enclosure
on the right this is a bioreactor from
sartorius and this instrument
is actually capable of performing inside
the biosafety cabinet
and can contain but we only know that
with most instruments after some
thorough testing
things like smoke airflow studies and
biological
containment challenges so it is
keen and really important to look at the
instruments that you may be using and
consult with the manufacturer of your
biosafety cabinet before progressing
so if we look at overcloud overcrowding
of a biosafety cabinet
really two factors play come into
account
and the first one is the size and the
second one is the shape of the
instrument
certainly the instrument has to fit
inside the biosafety cabinet in in
to be a successful installation but
after that
you also have to ensure that the smoke
or the airflow is going to generate
a smooth path around the instrumentation
in this image this is a view of a
laminar airflow product from lapcon co
and if you click play on your own you
will be able to see some of the smoke
flowing through the enclosure around
this large item
this is actually a large freeze dryer
and
while generally the performance of the
enclosure was compatible with this
equipment
you can see the air has to cascade
around that device
and in turn does pose an event that
creates some disruption and turbulence
where the airflow slots are
so it's really important to take note of
large equipment inside of enclosures for
these types of challenges
additionally um it's important to look
at the limitations that come with
robotics inside class 2 enclosures so as
you know
there are things like a glass sash
that's a protective barrier
and side walls that also just ensure the
cabinet contains and is robust
over its life but that poses a lot of
inherent challenges for robotic systems
so certainly with liquid handlers and
other instruments where there's a lot of
access requirements to load samples and
service
they can be obstructive and furthermore
on some biosafety cabinets there are
issues with
mitigating heat the most common type of
biosafety cabinet is a type a2 a class 2
type a2
and it recirculates a portion of its
error which also means that it will
recirculate a portion of its heat
output and for instruments especially
cell solders and flow cytometers that
can be problematic
um also just accessibility again um not
just for loading samples but for
maintenance and regular pms
um you know as you're thinking about
addressing the
service life of the instrument uh making
that easy for the servicer to come in
and complete their job
can be a real challenge in a biosafety
cabinet when the instrument may be very
heavy and loaded inside the enclosure
and cannot be easily lifted out with
more with just one person
so additionally just looking at
when you're incorporating those
instruments into biosafety enclosures
of all types it's important just to look
at the footprint of the enclosure
also look at the user accessibility
issues as i mentioned
you know on a typical biosafety cabinet
you have left right and rear
walls that are all stainless steel
construction with limited ability to
access instruments from the back and
sides
also a key thing to consider is the work
surface weight limit
on a traditional biosafety cabinet
listed to nsf-49
the work surface will be tested to a 50
pound
weight load some manufacturers allow for
more weight
lab conco does as well but it's
important to address
the amount of weight where it's going to
be positioned inside the biosafety
cabinet
and how the robot or other automated
system is going to be behaving
and redistributing weight as it operates
so checking with the manufacturer can
help out with those questions
also pass-throughs are a really
important consideration to make
many times an instrument can be bought
and not thought about
the service requirements for it so not
only power but
vacuum lines uh fluid lines and other
types of support
must be considered before purchasing a
biosafety cabinet
and and failure to do so may mean that
you uh
results in an inability to run the
cables out of the hood
so there are options to do that in all
types of biosafety cabinets
and they're definitely the preferred way
to pass cable in and out of the hood
as the front is not a solution that is
safe
just to highlight service accessibility
this happens to be a sell sorter
and the weight of this particular
instrument is over 200 pounds
so imagine trying to access that with a
black
blocked off rear wall can be quite
difficult
so liveconco's recently worked with
several manufacturers of different types
of lab instruments to come up with an
enclosure that meets a lot of these
challenges
we call it the logic view and and really
in designing this product we wanted to
marry all of the challenges of class 2
enclosures
both small and existing large enclosures
and really highlight a couple of key
features that address
safety convenience and intelligence
expectations
for all of you using these automated
instruments
so just looking briefly at the enclosure
you can see it's quite a bit different
in size and shape
it is a console style single unit
that rolls off of a on a baseband that
is built into the system
it's a class 2 enclosure so that means
that it's providing both
user and product protection and
also provides glass windows on all sides
so
in its design you're able to see any
automated instrument performing no
matter where you are in the laboratory
and that's really an important step not
only for
just being able to see all of the parts
of your instrumentation
but also to see it from a distance
across the lab certainly as automation
systems run
without user input or interaction it's
important to understand and quickly
glance and see that the system is
running safely
also just on the note of accessibility
many times automated liquid handlers can
be several hundred pounds and to be able
to support
access without completely dismantling
the system for service
this unit is provided with a both a
front and a rear
uh fully loading sash
the dimensions are also quite large as
well and you may think
well my automated system is maybe 25
inches tall
max why do i need anything more than 26
inches
and really that's the component that
matters most to the performance of a
class 2 enclosure is
ensuring that the airflow coming out of
the
product is not turbulent as it cascades
around the
automated instruments
so looking at the airflow just
representing how airflow is moving
through this design
the air is entering through the top of
the enclosure for the supply hepa filter
and pushing down through the work
surface after being passed through hepa
filters
on the left and right side of the unit
there are inflow arrows
and those are the protective arrows that
airflows that keep users safe during
operation
this unit has an eight inch sash opening
that runs the full width of the
instrument
to allow for full access to all of the
parts of the instrument during use
and to keep users safe it keeps a
minimum inflow
of 105 feet per minute just like a class
2 biosafety cabinet
the air is also exhausted through the
lower portion of the enclosure
and it goes back into the into the
laboratory or can be vented especially
if you're using something that has an
unpleasant smell or
is perhaps warranting
the use of exhaust for a different
reason
to make sure that these enclosures
perform uh there's a lot of work that
goes into
performance challenging and um and
that's done
in a biosafety cabinet by way of a
biological challenge
the methodology is used for biological
challenge assessments
are largely dictated by nsf standard 49
and involve the administration of
biological spores
across the work surface into the cabinet
and then also
out of the cabinet so these are just a
couple of representative images
blab conco performs these tests here in
addition to nsf as well for other types
of enclosures
and regularly uh evaluates the
performance of the products to ensure
that they're containing
under difficult practices and principles
and settings that users may be
using the enclosures in
controlling the system is also really
important as well
the the interface on a biosafety cabinet
is really the hub for users to
understand what's happening with an
enclosure
whether the filter life is is needing to
be replaced
understanding alerts and alarms and
doing so in with screens and images that
help quickly resolve images rather than
just simple
beeping noises and uh and difficult to
understand alerts so that's done
on on our platform using the myelogic
operating system
as simon was discussing it's also very
important to consider
the impact that the enclosure will have
to a automated liquid handler that has
panels
and so when those panels come off the
safety interlock method that was there
provided by those panels is removed and
to correct for that
and to still maintain that level of
safety that safety factor
it's important that the enclosure
provides an ability to have a safety
interlock
so this platform uses the screen in a
complex system to be able to speak with
liquid handlers and other automated
systems so that when the sash reaches a
opening
position it's also able to pause the
robotic system
and prevent users from being harmed
when these instruments are in a complex
building environment they also may
sometimes need to be connected to
a building management system and that
can easily be done with this platform as
well
some of the other things perhaps less
pertinent to safety but more important
to comfortable use
with enclosures is ensuring proper knee
space underneath the enclosure
and that means being able to reach in
and safely
position your body to load samples in
and out of the system
and also accommodating the other pieces
of equipment that go with the liquid
handler or an automation system for
support
so this particular logic view includes a
standard mounting system for ergotron
computer arms which are regularly
provided with
automated instruments and also the
adjustable
nature of the work surface is quite
important
we often see our users of biosafety
cabinets
processing hours of cell culture work a
day finding
ergonomics to be a key factor in their
comfort level
and so this enclosure also has the
ability to adjust upward or downward
depending on how
the users prefer to set the enclosure in
the laboratory and also
just depending on the interaction
requirements with their liquid handler
i mentioned weight earlier and that's
another key factor
not only just for support of the
instrument but also ensuring that the
enclosure does not flex or cause
inaccuracies with movements like
pipetting
or other interfaces uh and integrations
that are going to happen between
liquid handlers and other
instrumentation so the robust nature of
a work surface
is really although unseen is quite
important to the operation
of these systems and so on our system
it's able to support up to 750 pounds on
the six volt width
which is uh quite a clearance to allow
for
automated systems and all of the samples
that are loaded onto them
looking at pass-throughs is also a key
factor in
enclosure compatibility with automated
systems
and so as i mentioned earlier without
these being
available with a standard biosafety
cabinet in
great capacity it can be really
challenging to safely pass
cables in and out of the enclosure so on
the logic view there are many
opportunities for cables
there are passer cables for cord cords
and cables
and those are gas tight fixtures there
are also
lines for gas and vacuum valves
and lastly some instruments require
quite unique passers so
if you are working with something that
requires a vacuum line
or especially if you're working with a
cell sorter that has
a requirement for an airflow management
system those systems can be easily
passed out with specialty
flanges on our enclosures to allow for
compatibility with all types of
instruments
sometimes your users may be finding
that their system needs to be scaled up
and
using robotics runners or other
linear movement movement platforms to
provide
a larger more complex environment for
automation
and that can be accomplished regularly
within the logic view which has the
ability to connect multiple units
together
to side by side so you can see here this
is a
configuration of two units placed side
by side which allows for a total working
width
of over 12 feet
additionally um one one wanted to
revisit just
the importance of looking at the
compatibility of your instrument
uh in an enclosure and that starts again
with looking at the instrument size
requirements
looking at the ergonomic requirements
for operation and service so you can see
here this gentleman is loading an
evo platform and it's easy to do so
because the sash swings all the way open
and provides great
access to the interior
also ensuring again cords cables and
fluid lines are
are considered before purchasing an
enclosure with the logic view you don't
have to worry so much about
compatibilities
because there is quite a bit of
flexibility but if there are unique
lines involved it's really important
to consider those dimensional
requirements for those tubes
also looking at waste and this is
perhaps one of the most important
considerations with automated liquid
handlers
different ways to accomplish the removal
of pipettes
pipette tips from the systems and as
you're doing that
different liquid handling systems have
different requirements so it's best to
consult with
your automation specialist on what
you'll be using and then also working
with
to assess that the waste can be safely
removed from the enclosure
we have different ways of doing that but
it encodes a careful assessment before
purchasing a unit
additionally as you get these units into
facilities as simon mentioned earlier
it's really
keen uh important for you to consider
the
dimensional requirements for the
doorways for the loading dock and other
locations that you'll be receiving
instrumentation
so with the logic view the installation
minimum requirement is eight foot six
inches
so it's often uh safe to say that a
eight and a half foot ceiling will be
compatible
more is obviously better if available
also doorways and hallways and the
loading dock as i mentioned
are really important to evaluate the
logic view can be stripped down to a
much smaller size for passageway through
standard doors
but at the same time it's important to
understand that before just receiving
the equipment and pushing it straight
into your lab you may run into some
challenges that require additional
installation requirement
also power is really important both
understanding the power requirements for
your automation
instrumentation and also in for the
enclosure itself
oftentimes the larger the enclosure the
more energy required
and while not insurmountable it does
take careful planning
as oftentimes a typical 115 outlet
for a small instrument may not be
sufficient
i also want to talk about exhaust
requirements for those of you who may be
handling solvents
or other things that may require exhaust
the logic view can be exhausted just
like most bio safety cabinets
and to do so it's really important to
evaluate the mechanical system
due to the size of a automation
enclosure there's a high volume of air
that is exhausted throughout the system
and then combinating that on the
building building system and its exhaust
is
is really important to evaluate before
purchasing the equipment
and lastly uh also important to visit
the
requirements uh for for making sure that
the
unit can get safely into its space and
also tested so as you're considering
these
it's important to understand the
installation requirements
live common code certainly can help with
some of those challenges but also
working on the
testing of the equipment before it's
used by a user
and what this means is that when the
system is purchased
the the automation enclosure it should
be put into place first
and certified empty to make sure that
it's operating correctly
and then again evaluated by the
certifier after the instruments
that are going to be placed inside of it
are are set
and that's to ensure not only that the
unit was operating
the enclosure was operating safely first
but secondarily to make sure that
the instrument that's being placed
inside is properly functioning and not
disrupting airflow significantly
again on the insulation side that means
coordinating both with
labconco on the delivery of the
instrument also
coordinating closely with the automation
platform
we we find the best integrations are
where
the users of the instrumentation are
closely working with
automation enclosure and also the
automation
equipment providers specialists to
ensure that all
pieces of equipment arrive on time and
are
successfully integrated together
and again test the unit before it's it's
loaded with
automation and then again at the uh
the delivery and completion of the
installation of the automation system
all right that is the end of my slides i
know we've had a couple of questions
so thank you again and i think we will
dive into the questions now
thank you david and simon for your
informative presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
do we need a biosafety enclosure for our
covid samples we are running both
abbott id now and pcr assays
uh great question um yes if the virus
has not been
inactivated prior to testing it does
need to be contained
in a biosafety enclosure that provides
personnel protection
so while that may be a class one
enclosure oftentimes the
sensitivity of those tests is
strongly warrants the use of a class two
bio safety cabinet
so if you have those instruments or if
you're running a larger
application with an automated liquid
handler or otherwise
it's definitely warranted to place that
into a class 2 dsc
if not only for the cleaner but
certainly for safety as well
okay thank you so much and we have a
another question here
um well this person's asking what does
bio safety enclosure mean
yeah good question um so the the term is
broad
when we're talking about a bio safety
cabinet or a biosafety enclosure we're
talking about at a minimum something
that protects the user
so it's going to be providing negative
pressure airflow into the cabinet
or enclosure to keep them safe so
that's why it is important to look at
all biosafety containment options out
there
and understand what your requirements
for the enclosure
is so if you have an expectation for
personnel protection
or user protection you need a biosafety
enclosure but if you also have
requirements for clean air it's
important to
understand and also purchase a unit that
is going to provide class 2 airflow
which is
protecting both the user and their
samples
i noticed there's another question about
biosafety enclosures requiring uv light
other than wiping down with 70
alcohol this is a really uh important
question to consider with your
biosafety officer first for the
organisms that you're going to be
handling
and ensuring that you're adhering to the
recommended practices of your
organization
but also looking at the the enclosure
and its compatibility to be
disinfected with those different
chemicals
the this question mentions 70 alcohol
and certainly that's a pretty widely
used enclosure
uh or a disinfectant uh solution for
enclosures and robotics
but not all things are susceptible to
being fully disinfected with 70
alcohol so important to first look at
what's required for your organisms that
you'll be handling
secondarily uv light while commonly
found in in class 2 biosafety cabinets
is not as common in large automation
enclosures and
and oftentimes not available and there
are two
major reasons for that one is that uv
light
is only effective on surfaces when it is
effective it is only effective on
surfaces that can directly shine onto
so when you have a large safety
enclosure that has automation
instrumentation into it
uv light is going to be inherently
blocked by the large equipment
and most if a large part if not most of
the interior of the enclosure will not
be disinfected
effectively by a uv light so that is why
it's typically not recommended
for anytime instrumentation is placed
into any kind of biosafety
enclosure the other reason is that
the enclosures themselves again lots of
places
in cracks and areas are difficult to
clean but also they
the instruments themselves can be
susceptible to damage from uv light
things like fiber optic cables and data
lines can degrade over time with uvs
so it's really important to look at the
requirements
for the instrumentation and really
identify a good chemical disinfectant
first
and foremost as your primary form of
disinfection
thank you david our next question here
is what's the difference between bsc
2 a and b
good question so a class 2 biosafety
cabinet
is a overall it is a unit that provides
personnel or user protection
and also sample protection or product
protection
type a and type b are subsets of the
class 2 biosafety cabinet family
a is very common on a regular
traditional biosafety cabinet a type a2
recirculates portion of its air
and its function while a type b2
provides 100 exhaust to the outside b2
cabinets are often
purchased with the expectation that they
run safer
for users they are the only difference
though is that they exhaust
chemicals to the outside without any
recirculation so if chemicals are going
to be used they can provide
some protection additionally over an a2
that would be can to be connected but
generally speaking um it's uh
yeah it's reserved largely for chemical
use only
and how do we measure that a bsc is
working properly
so first fourth and foremost the the
measure of
biosafety cabinet working properly is
its initial certification
after installation that's typically done
by a technician who's got lots of
experience in training and doing that
they measure the air flow that's the
inflow and the downflow speeds
they'll also look at the leak filter
leaking
of the filters and they'll challenge the
filters to make sure that they are
leak-free they'll also make sure that
they understand um the the automation
system that's gonna be placed into the
cabinet if that's gonna be used
and evaluate that platform with smoke
visualization studies
as well the next question is
we have a liquid handler that just
barely fits inside our normal tissue
culture hood is this safe to operate
good question um if it just barely fits
inside
to i mean as a manufacturer of biosafety
cabinets with lots of experience testing
such installations it is uh
it is difficult to make a black and
white answer
so the best thing to do is to first
consult your biosafety officer on site
involve your regular certification
professional who's going to be testing
the biosafety cabinet as well
and um and then also consulting with the
manufacturer of the biosafety cabinet
and with the manufacturer of the
instrument that's going to be placed
inside
the there are fairly ineffective or
sorry fairly
inexpensive tests that can be run using
smoke visualization to assess
containment
however the only full dead
dead set way to ensure that the cabinet
is operating safely is to use a
biological challenge assessment
which typically is performed
at the manufacture of the biosafety
cabinet site
great thank you so much for that answer
and our next question is
what does bsl bsl-2 mean
a good question um so depending on your
location around the world you may have
different
uh requirements um when you are
adhering to biosafety considerations
around the world
so who guidelines or cdc
or others and each one of them will have
classifications
for the organisms that are going to be
handled the risk group that they
participate in
and then their subsequent requirements
for the facility and
instrumentation and equipment that are
used to handle those organisms
typically at least in accordance with
the cdc
uh in north america or in the united
states
bsl2 organisms are the first
level minimum level that user protection
is required in addition to protection
for the organisms
the question that certainly your on-site
biosafety or ehs personnel can help
answer as well if you have a question
about a particular organism
okay and our next question here is when
you join
two of the large logic view units
together can you remove the center wall
so the 12 foot bench is totally clear
left to right
yes you can okay
perfect and what differs with the
airflow
observed in a clean bench compared with
the class 1 and class 2 bsc
sure a clean bench is going to be
providing clean air flow
just over the work surface that's blown
out towards the user
so someone who is working with
non-hazardous samples
will have the ability to work in a clean
environment
but there is no protective environment
that is provided to them
a class one bsc is the opposite it
provides protection for users
but it does not provide a clean air flow
environment
and a class 2 vsc combines the two and
provides clean air and also user
protection at the same time
great thank you so much and our next
question here is
my liquid handler has a hepa filter that
came with the instrument
does this hepa filter provide any
protection from biohazards
it would not typically most of
the instrumentation that's out there
that includes hepa filtration just
provides a clean air
style airflow and would not provide
user protection whatsoever of course
there are a hand small handful of them
out there that are
providing user protection as well but
it's best to consult the provider of
that instrumentation
okay thank you david and our next
question let's see is it safe to operate
microbiological testing in a clean bench
it really depends on the organisms that
are going to be handled so
for instance something like a
non-hazardous yeast specimen would be
safe to handle on a clean bench but you
would absolutely not want to handle
something that is pathogenic
to humans in a clean bench
okay and in a td molecular lab can we
use
uv light as an additional measure of
sterilization
yeah ultimately this is a recommendation
that you're going to work
along with your biosafety officer on
site specifically tb
which is you know regularly regularly
quite difficult to inactivate due to its
waxy
cell wall is going to require a heavy
chemical disinfection first
uv light certainly does not hurt any
type of chemical disinfection practices
but it really should only be used as a
secondary measure
after validation and disinfection with
chemicals
okay thank you david and we have
one more question here oh
let's see what's the ideal way of how
should you move your arms basically
while working inside a bsc what is the
ideal way to move your arms
yeah um anytime you're working in a
controlled or critical airflow
environment
slow methodical movements are best they
help
to eliminate disruption of airflow the
most
rather than swinging your arms around
and disrupting airflow
so the slower and more methodical you
can work to the best the better
outcome you will have
okay and we have another question that
just came in does ahu
have any effect on bsc efficiency
not exactly sure what ahu means it may
be air handling units
which would typically be a generic term
to
cover the term or the instrument moving
airflow in and out of the
facility um like a hvac system
would typically not have any impact on
a biosafety cabinet's efficiency unless
the questioner asked the person who's
asking the question is
asking about an air handling exhaust
blower that would be supplying exhaust
air from a biosafety cabinet
so in that case if it was being you know
talking about an exhaust blower
then it would be it depends on the type
of
bsc installation
okay great thank you so much thank you
david and simon
both of you do you have any comments uh
final comments for our audience
just wanted to say thank you very much
for everybody who
took the time to listen today
yes likewise thanks so much everyone for
joining
well thank you again david and simon for
your time today and for your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor labconco for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye